we are ghosts
we aren't afraid of death
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2016 j skell completed the
construction of the new scale technology
headquarters on aurora an island in the
south pacific ocean
skel has the brains power and money to
do incredible things like turning an
entire island into the headquarters of
skeltec but he also has a sense of hope
hope that he can use his technology to
help the world
scale technology is a blue chip company
producing drones for commercial
applications but it also has found
success as a military contractor
developing cutting-edge equipment for
the united states government
scale purchased aurora with a vision of
turning it into a hub for the design
research development and production of
artificial intelligence and drone
technology
by 2024 aurora was home to more than 30
000 residents and internal security had
become a requirement so a private
military company named sentinel was
hired
over time as skeltek became more
advanced and started to become
autonomous the potential risk opposed to
humanity started to get noticed
concerns of what would happen if it were
to fall into the wrong hands were being
raised
faced with mounting evidence that its
products were ending up in the hands of
corrupt regimes scale technology starts
coming under increased public scrutiny
then in 2025
aurora mysteriously went quiet
when the company was implicated in an
assassination the united states
government decides to investigate
further
only for aurora to cut itself off from
the outside world
with allegations towards the company the
us government decides to send in the
ghosts
nomad now promoted to lieutenant colonel
was sent in with the team of 32 ghosts
under his command their mission was to
investigate the island and if possible
extract j skel
nomad and his team were flown onto the
island but on their way are taken down
by a drone swarm
the majority of these ghosts wouldn't
even step foot on a rower
after crash landing on the island nomad
attempts to regroup with his team while
overcoming a series of obstacles put in
place by a mysterious group that is
hunting them down
they find out that this group is led by
a former ghost and close colleague col d
walker
he has gone rogue
and then a private military contractor
named sentinel has occupied the island
under walker's command
and walker himself is leading a team of
soldiers
calling themselves
the wolves
walker came from a military family in
fact he was fourth generation army
after graduating at the top of his class
he was groomed and fast-tracked into a
strategic command career for field
operations
walker was quickly headhunted for the
first special forces operational
detachment otherwise known as delta
force
but was eventually recruited by the
elite special mission unit known as the
ghosts
during operation kingslayer the ghosts
were called in by the cia contact bowman
to extract his skull tech research and
development technical director daniel
who'd been arrested by unidad
daniel had knowledge of sensitive u.s
industrial secrets that needed to be
protected at all
costs after eventually hunting him down
they found that fellow ghost team leader
major col d walker had arrived there
first
but he was working under his own agenda
[Music]
walker had found out that daniel was the
one who designed an advanced
surveillance drone for uni dad
they had then weaponized it and used it
to kill two of walker's team
walker agreed to help the ghosts extract
daniel so he could meet up with bowman
but curious as to why bowman was keeping
him alive he stayed close by to
investigate
bowman had to face walker's accusations
and explained that she was following
orders from her superiors
daniel had become a key uni-dead
informer and she had to protect him in
order to secure multiple us interests in
bolivia
february 2022
walker nomad along with several other
ghosts were deployed in the middle east
to run counter-terrorism operations
later on in the operation walker found
himself in an altercation with his
commanding officer vaughn who had just
killed the civilian
this ended with walker killing the
officer
this man happened to be the son of a u.s
senator
it was beginning to get too much for
walker with no incoming support and
watching his brothers getting gunned
down around him
he felt trapped and alone
he started questioning who and what he
was fighting for
enough was enough from political
protection of traitors who had two of
his men killed to being abandoned and
ignored by officers behind desks in
times of war and finally witnessing sons
of senators not being held accountable
for their actions
he believes mankind has lost its way and
the upper classes and privileged need to
be brought in line
walker officially left the us army in
july of 2022
then after gathering support from
several fellow ghosts
walker went rogue and launched an attack
killing former brothers and even one of
the senior ghost command
in 2024 walker came on board as jskell's
military advisor as he had begun to take
an interest in skeltek's advanced
military technology
however it wasn't long before walker and
his wolves rallied together with
sentinel and took control of aurora
all communications 2 and from aurora
were shut down
using j-scale's cutting-edge technology
walker tracked down the people who were
responsible for the deaths of his men
back in bolivia
he then used the state-of-the-art drones
from skeltec to assassinate the
political candidate responsible for the
murders around this time
these were the actions that triggered
operation greenstone with 32 ghosts were
flown in by helicopter to investigate
the island
the same drone swans that walker was
using to keep the residents from
escaping was also stopping anyone from
entering the island
walker plans to use the skeltek drones
as a solution to what he describes as a
nation under god forsaken fools
liberated by lies justified by
complacency
that the moral high ground it was built
upon has already begun to erode
[Music]
armed with cutting-edge weapons and
equipment the wolves have commandeered
scale technologies drone production as
part of a self-appointed mission to
safeguard the future of warfare
walker has made nomad and his team a
target and he's willing to do whatever
it takes to give his hold on a rower
nomad and the ghosts find shelter at
erawan which is home to the homesteaders
a group who lived on aurora before
skeltek's arrival
nomad manages to find another ghost
josiah hill
following this nomad locates jay skell
but is then attacked by walker and hill
who is defected to walker's side
nomad escapes along with skell
skelvin formulates a plan to take down
the drone control program
along the way nomads and the ghosts help
out key employees of scale tech
eliminate sentinel commanders and
walker's lieutenants
eventually nomad manages to track down
walker and after a gruelling fight nomad
manages to inflict a fatal blow
with his dying breaths walker hands his
dog tags to nomad
[Music]
nomad then deactivates the drone control
program by uploading skel's virus taking
down the drones protecting the island
and stopping walker's plan of taking out
the world leaders
which involved using lethal killer
drones that were to be deployed by
missiles launched from a submarine
strategically placed away from the main
island of varroa gollum island was home
to a military research unit specializing
in the creation of experimental drones
due to the sensitive nature of the
research skeltek implemented a
self-learning ai to monitor the whole
island and protect the valuable
resources on it
following walker's death a faction of
wolves called the red wolves take over
gollum island
after infiltrating the area the red
wolves managed to reconfigure the
self-learning ai bringing it under their
control
nomad and the ghosts infiltrate this
hostile environment and manage to stop
the red wolves as well as their four
massive military drones called titans
before they were able to reach full
production
no man is informed of a woman who has
been captured by sentinel who was able
to take down several armed drones on her
own
he tracks her down
she introduces herself as rasa aldwin a
time traveler sent from the future to
search for nomad
however while they are talking a t-800
terminator arrives at the scene forcing
them to escape
making the way to rasa's workshop she
explains that 40 years from now in her
timeline an artificial intelligence
known as skynet would be responsible for
developing the machines for
infiltration-based assassination
missions
and would use the machines to wage war
on humanity
she has come back to 2025 to warn nomad
but she has been followed
they are here to kill nomad and rasa and
secure the future of controlling
earth the terminators are a cybernetic
enemy that is resistant to conventional
weapons
however rasa has made a special weapon
for nomad they can pierce the t800s
armor and fry their mainframes
nomad investigates the presence of
multiple terminators on aurora and after
detecting strange electromagnetic
patterns coming from one of the
skeltique facilities
nomad discovers that the machines have
converted the facility into a terminator
mass production factory
reaching the control room nomad comes
across the t-800 that originally
encountered them and is now in control
of the facility
after battling and destroying the
original t800 nomad seals the airlock
leading into the production facility
trapping the remaining terminators
inside while the entire compound
self-destructs
[Music]
splinter cells sam fisher has been
deployed in aurora alongside his friend
victor cost under the appearance of
working for cost's private security
company paladin 9.
though it looks as though pallet and 9
are working alongside sentinel to
provide logistical support they are
actually investigating the kidnappings
of military specialists that have been
traced back to an individual on the
island known as the strategist
fischer and nomad team up and discover
that the strategist is working on a top
secret program called project claw
which is an artificial intelligence hive
mind which enables human controlled
drone swarms capable for military
application
they eventually find the strategist's
identity to be leon ferro a billionaire
industrialist and head of weapons
manufacturing corporation lomax ferro
pharah's partner is michael lomax
and as a u.s senator they are a part of
a conspiracy involving several other
high-ranking members throughout the u.s
government
the cia and department of defense sent
in the fourth echelon to investigate
after infiltrating project clause
research facility and facing off against
an array of drones
fisher and nomad managed to capture
pharaoh
finding a small window of opportunity
fischer and cost managed to sneak past
the drone swarm defending the island and
escape with pharaoh on board
they plan to take him back and force him
to testify before congress in hopes that
his testimony will convince them to
officially launch a u.s military
invasion of aurora to remove sentinel
after the defeat of walker and project
claw trey stone the commander of
sentinel allied up with raven's rock
a russian ultra-nationalist terrorist
group
together they plan on launching a
massive bioweapon attack on the united
states called operation king maker
the goal is to use drones loaded with
chemical weapons provided by the bodak
to conduct a mass assassination of u.s
officials allowing a designated survivor
to take control of the american
government
scott mitchell nomads commanding officer
became aware of this plot and contacted
the remaining ghosts on aurora
nomad was able to hunt down and
eliminate key members of raven's rock
including the infamous bodak team
in an act of desperation stone attempted
to activate the drones to carry out the
attack
but nomad was able to kill stone
eliminating the threat
in turn leading to several members of
the us government to be arrested
later in 2025 team rainbow learned of a
nerve gas called amber ruin that was
being mass produced on the remote island
of arora to be sold onto foreign
militaries and terrorist groups
and that the private military company
called sentinel was behind it
legion got in contact with scott
mitchell to conduct a joint operation
with ghost recon called operation amber
sky to stop all production identify
potential buyers and create an antidote
once in contact with nomad legion
explained the situation and sent in
specialists ash thatcher and finka
they were able to enter the island by
replacing a potential buyer
shortly after a sentinel transmission
was intercepted it spoke of an amber
ruin attack on the island
nomad went to investigate
there were no survivors
the biochemical attack had killed
everyone on site
they would soon find out that this was a
deliberate attack to test the effects of
the gas
shortly afterwards the commanding
officer in charge of the test arrived
nomad grabbed the officer and
interrogated him
he was able to find out the location of
the test results
nomad took the data and brought it to a
doctor who had agreed to formulate an
antidote
rainbow and nomad then managed to locate
a skeltique engineer who was in charge
of an amber ruined mass production
facility
nomad attacked the compound eliminating
sentinel and destroying the gas emitter
next they travel to multiple amber and
shipping facilities around aurora and
place trackers on each shipping
container this way they will be able to
see who's been purchasing the chemical
weapon
more production facilities were
identified on the island and then
destroyed
the doctor working on the antidote was
making progress but was struggling with
the final steps
legion informed nomad of a colleague of
the doctor who had invaluable
information that was required for the
completion of the antidote
nomad and rainbow managed to rescue him
from the sentinel forces and flew him
and his research to safety
with the antidote well on its way rambo
would then apprehend the terrorist
buyers worldwide after tracking and
confiscating the amberuan shipments
and this brings us up to date with the
story leading into the recently
announced operation motherland where the
cia has been working with the outcasts
on aurora who are attempting to have it
become a free and autonomous nation
cia contact bowman has sent a nomad in a
squad to assist
with this new operation coming up i've
been spending a little more time on
breakpoint recently i needed to refresh
my memory on where we were at as i've
been busy with other games in real life
so i thought i'd chuck this together as
a quick update or wrap up of the story
so far
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]